okay thank you for joining us
for this press conference following the
meeting of the leaders
of the members of the european council i
mean we are joined here by the president
of the commission and the president of
the european council
i give the floor to mr michelle first
merci beaucoup
europe difficile particularly
[Applause]
[Music]
turkey and you know that turkey and the
east
mediterranean is a very important
priority for the european union for the
member states
you know also that this is a difficult
debate it's not the first time that we
have this debate
and we prepared very well the
conclusions
that are agreed conclusions
uh which are based on a double idea
first we have decided to task
the commission and the high
representative in order to
propose a possible positive agenda
possible for the agenda but conditional
it means
that we hope that turkey will maintain
a moderate behavior a positive behavior
in the next weeks
and in the next month and it means that
we are ready with the european
council with the member states to put
more concrete proposals on the table in
order to have
a more stable a more predictable
relationship with
turkey and we have identified the
possible topics in order to improve the
relationships
first the mobilization of the custom
unions
people-to-people activities and mobility
and of course the migration topic
and this is our intention to work
very hard in a d in order to be able to
put
some concrete proposals on the table and
we will have the opportunity
to come back again in june at the level
of the open curtain in order i hope
to take more formal decisions but this
step
is an important step in the right
direction
this an important topic on russia
it was just an information point and we
intend
to have on the forthcoming european
council
the strategy debate on russia but we
know
uh what are our position because we had
the opportunity the last days
to express the european position on
russia
and then we had also the opportunity to
tackle some
economic topics the single market and
the digital agenda
you know that with the green deal the
digital ambition
is one of the two fundamental pillars
for the new european model for the new
european
paradigm and with the decisions that we
took today
through those conclusions that we have
agreed on
we give a very strong signal that we
will work
actively with the commission with the
memberships in order to
use the digital ambition as
a leverage in order to improve the
economic development to improve the
innovation
and to make clear what are our
priorities in the short term in the
midterm
and in the longer term today
foreign
last but not least we had the
opportunity
tonight to have an exceptional euro
summit because
for the first time in 11 years we
welcomed the president of the united
states last time
it was seven years ago with barack obama
and it was the opportunity for the
president of the united states
to express his vision about the future
cooperation between
the eu and the united states and it was
also the opportunity for us
the european union to to express our
very strong commitment for this
fundamental to the atlantic alliance
on our location
[Music]
thank you thank you varend good evening
so indeed
this was a long and good european
council
we started by discussing covet 19
and this in a situation where we have an
epidemiological situation of great
concern
we are at the start of the third wave in
europe
and in many european member states
infections are on the rise again
mostly due to the variant
b117 that is basically now in every
member state
but fortunately mortality
increases remain however lower
than the spread of the virus so we see
the very first
effects of having vaccinated most of the
over 80 years old
but overall the situation is of great
concern
and this highlights the importance of a
fast and speedy vaccination
now we took stock of
where we are at the moment being a week
before the end of the first quarter of
2021
vaccination is now finally progressing
steadily
we have 88 million doses that have been
delivered
so far and 62 million doses have been
administered overall if you look at the
number of people that have been fully
vaccinated in europe these are 18.2
million
so 4.1 percent have already received
two jobs but of course we all know we
could have been much
faster if all pharmaceutical companies
had fulfilled their contracts now
looking forward to the second quarter
we basically see the same picture uh we
have biotech and moderna that have been
delivering
very reliable and according to schedule
and contract
thus we expect that they will increase
their deliveries as is contracted
in the second quarter and that's to gain
pace
additionally we see that now johnson
johnson is kicking in
in the second quarter and let me remind
you that
johnson johnson vaccine only requires
a single shot for full vaccination
astrazeneca has committed to a lower
number of doses than was contracted
here astrazeneca has committed to 17
million doses instead of the contracted
180 million doses but overall
if we have a look at the second quarter
what is committed
it means that we are on track to achieve
our goal
that this summer we want to have 70
percent of the adult population in the
european union
vaccinated i
also presented to the leaders the latest
changes for the transparency and export
mechanism
for experts of covet 19 vaccines
you know that yesterday
we added to the scope of this mechanism
the criteria of reciprocity and
proportionality
just to be very clear we want to make
sure
that europe gets its fair share of
vaccines
because we must be able to explain to
our citizens
that if companies export their vaccines
to the whole world
it is because they are fully honoring
their commitments
and it does not risk security of supply
in the european union
and let there be no mistake the european
union
can be proud and is proud to be the home
of vaccine producers
who not only deliver to european
citizens but export
around the globe also the european
union is and will forever be a fervent
supporter
of global cooperation our track record
speaks for itself
and it was good to create this
transparency
since the start of the mechanism on the
1st of february
more than 380 export requests
to 33 different countries have been
granted
and only one has been stopped and the
figures are even more impressive if you
calculate
the amount of doses between first press
if you calculate
the amount of doses between first of
december
and today that have been exported
overall up to date the total number of
experts from the european union
has risen to 77 million doses
that shows that europe is the region
that exports the most vaccines worldwide
and we will continue exporting also
through covax and to protect
humanitarian
and health workers around the world so
the bottom line is
we invite others to match our openness
the fight against the pandemic of course
was also
one of the topics addressed with
president biden
tonight we were indeed glad for this
exchange of views
the european union and the united states
are both
major producers of vaccines and we
agreed that we have a strong
interest in working together to keep
global supply chains
functioning and to prepare already
for the next challenges to come in this
pandemic
in an area of pandemics the united
states is an important and valued
partner to the european union
and we want to forge a new eu us
global agenda to meet the challenges but
also to seize the opportunities
of our times and indeed this comes
on top of the excellent discussions i
had with secretary of state anthony
blinken
just yesterday the european union and
the united states must develop together
true solutions
set ambitious objectives and then work
together
to achieve them it was interesting
to see the agenda the topics that have
been presented by president biden
of course first of all how to get
covered 19 under control
but indeed his second major topic
was fighting climate change and to drive
an inclusive economic growth that is
clean
and sustainable his third topic was
to lead the economic recovery to a
jobs-rich recovery we share this common
ambition
and how to boost innovation on
cutting-edge technologies
and finally indeed that we stand united
as democracies defending human rights
and defending human dignity
finally a few remarks on turkey the
discussion on turkey we had
as you know president michelle and me we
spoke to president erdogan last friday
since the december european council
turkey has shown
a more constructive attitude including
in its bilateral relations with several
eu member states
these are positive and welcome steps
on which we must try to build on however
we also know that
this progress of de-escalation remains
fragile
so together with high representative
borrel we submitted a report
on the state of play of eu turkey
political
economic and trade relations as well as
on
instruments and options on how to
proceed now with
this relationship and in light of
turkish recently more constructive
attitude
the report puts forward possible areas
of cooperation to allow for a
progressive
and proportionate approach we have
decided in the european council to go
for
two-step approach we will further engage
with turkey on issues such as migration
financing
high-level dialogues and modernizing the
customs union
if turkey does not move forward
construction
constructively if it returns to
unilateral actions or provocations
in particular in the eastern
mediterranean of course
we would suspend these cooperation
measures
and finally the commission got invited
by council to present a proposal to the
council
for the continuation of the financing
for syrian refugees as well
as in turkey as in jordan and lebanon
and other parts of the region thank you
thank you madam president before turning
to the q a
um i would just like to point out that
we've just
released the statement of the members of
the european council so i invite you
kindly
to check that on our website on all
foreign matters and on covet and all the
other topics that were addressed
during this meeting can i uh please ask
you to switch on your cameras we've got
translation into six languages and we've
got a lot of questions
but i'm first going to turn to christian
spielmann
the iv christian
is
yes we are we have agreed that we have
now a time
to look at the attitude of
turkey in these different matters it is
very clear for me that the istanbul
convention
is an important milestone forward in
protecting
women and protecting children and we
deplore that
turkey has left the istanbul convention
although we also call on member states
in the european union
to ratify the istanbul convention so for
us it is important
to move forward in this important matter
it is an overall self-explaining
necessity
that there is an understanding how to
protect uh women against violence
how to protect children against violence
thank you madam president we have nicos
from bloomberg
who's next nicos hello can you hear me
yes yes it wasn't clear to me from your
introductory remarks
what exactly was decided today has
the council decided or not tougher
curbs on vaccine exports
also given the fact that uh it seems
that the eu has exported more vaccines
than it has
administered so far and the a second
more specific question if i may
uh i have you did you discuss at all the
subject of
astra more specifically especially the
curious case in italy and also the fact
that the company with
just five days to go before the end of
the quarter
is way behind its reduced target of
deliveries thank you
so um of course we have discussed the
overall mechanism
it is very good that we introduced that
mechanism because what we wanted is
first of all transparency
and we have created transparency and
that is a transparency on exports where
we can take
pride be proud of we can take pride in
the fact that the european union
is one of the most open regions
when it comes to vaccines and
pharmaceutical
products and we invite others to join us
in this openness because we know we have
worldwide supply chains
that have to be intact and
it is of utmost importance that we get
back to an attitude
where in general there is openness for
export
that was point number one the
transparency that is necessary
but of course um we have to and want to
explain to our european citizens that
they get
their fair share and therefore the
second principle
is that companies have to honor their
contract
to the european union before
they export
to other regions in the world and this
is of course the case with astrazeneca
i think it is clear for the company that
first of all the company has to catch up
has to honor the contract it has with
the european
member states before it can engage again
in exporting in exporting
vaccines and the third element is
that we are discussing with the
companies
that they keep proportionality and
reciprocity
as a principle the reciprocity element
is something where we needed also
transparency to show
how much is going in different countries
that are
also producing vaccines so that it is in
our common interests
that supply chains stay intact that an
exchange
of vaccines is the normal state of play
and to have these principles in place
again
those companies who do deliver those
companies who
honor their contract these are the ones
on which basically the whole supply is
relying
and therefore for us it's important to
have a very constructive
approach with these companies to be in a
constant dialogue what we are on a daily
basis to make sure that
we deliver to the european uh citizens
but that we also
deliver to the world
oh excuse me i have not answered
your question on the on the vaccines in
italy
you were asking that too here the
company has uh
um has made clear that of the
um 29 million doses 13 million doses
are for covax and 16 million doses
are for european member states
and indeed we for us is important
that vaccines are being delivered to
to kovacs kovacs is the main pillar to
make sure that law and middle-income
countries have access to vaccines
the drug substance that has been used
for fill and finish in the italian
production site came from south korea
and china and um this was
and is the usual way to um work on
producing the vaccines for coverage
maybe just a few words there is a very
strong consensus among the member states
first
uh we want to guarantee the supply
chains and we want an open economy
but at the same time we want more
transparency and this
the goal with this mechanism put on the
table by the by the commission
and we want to make sure that the the
contracts
are fulfilled and indeed there are some
concerns serious concerns
with regard to this one company and we
hope that with the support of this
tool this instrument it will be possible
to to increase
not only the production and the delivery
and then finally another important part
a few
weeks ago in a newsletter i've tried to
explain
that europe is a major producer
of vaccines we export a lot of vaccines
and we have all the tools in order to
in order to succeed and to increase the
production
and to deliver more doses in the next
week
thank you mr president we have uh angela
maro from huffington post
angela you have the floor
angela there you are
could you please unmute
hello we can't hear you
we'll take another question
maria mariapsara you are next
from opentv maria hello can you hear me
can you see me maybe
we can hear you and see you okay so
two questions on turkey if i may you
mentioned migration
modernizing custom union two things that
turkey has been asking for a long time
could you say that this is the beginning
of the new era between
for the relationship between the eu and
turkey
and the second question you are
considering of going
to turkey that's what you said after the
teleconference with
president erdogan will this trip be
before
june do you know already thanks
to two points first point i can only
repeat a twist this decision that we
that we took today we have a clear
framework and
we hope we really hope it will be
possible to improve the relationship
with turkey but at the same time
i repeat that for us it's important that
turkey
keep a positive behavior a moderate
behavior and we hope that the dialogue
will be
fruitful but we remain we remain
cautious and remain careful and indeed
we are in contact with
the turkish authorities in order to pay
a visit probably in april
to turkey well what
the migration topic is concerned
um we think the commission was mandated
today
or invited by the council to work on
that as you know
there is the eu uh turkey statement
since
2016 first of all the
return and resettlement mechanism
has to be put in place again and
secondly indeed
um so far the six billion in this
um eu turkey statement have been
contracted by now
four billion have been dispersed the
other projects are still ongoing
we have the uh financial contribution
for bridging
time frame till the end of 2021
it is important we think to
continue to engage in this field for
very simple reason
turkey is hosting um 3.6
million syrian refugees and
there's a major contribution from the
european union
to support those syrian refugees beat
schooling for the
children 2 million children are
in school during that time have been in
school during that time
be it support for for example medical
medical appointments but also be
investment
in the infrastructure without any doubt
turkey is shouldering
the major the lion's share of the burden
but we think
it is important to keep on going
with the support in this humanitarian
cause
concerning the syrian refugees in turkey
and the discussion
and negotiations will go on how to
proceed
with this eu turkey statement this is
one of the major topics we will
certainly discuss
thank you we'll take a question from
politico david
hersenhorten david you're next thanks
very much brent
a question for each president if i can
president michelle i wonder if you could
talk to us about
uh your conversation with president
biden and specifically if he'd made any
offer
to send vaccines at some point to the eu
perhaps even to austria
to help you out in various ways and for
president fender line
on the export control mechanism i wonder
if how you would react to folks who say
as this pandemic era leads to a boom in
the vaccine industry will this
discourage
companies from setting up in the eu
because they see these sorts of
bureaucratic restrictions and also given
the numbers you presented
should your friend boris johnson also
come forward with his numbers of exports
of vaccines around the world thank you
both
in fact i i would like to repeat again
that uh
europe exports a lot of doses everywhere
in the in the world and the top priority
is to increase
the production of vaccines and literally
are convinced that it's important to
have a very strong cooperation
with the united states when it when it
comes to distraction
of the supply chain that is why the
commission and especially
thierry bertone and the task force they
are in touch
with the american administration in
order to guarantee
the supply chains and the certainty for
us in europe that you are able
in the next weeks and months to produce
more doses
and we cooperate also with the united
states and with other
countries in the world when it comes to
the kovacs facility
you know that uh we played a very
important role the european union
union you know to launch this initiative
because
with joe biden and we repeat it this uh
conviction we will not be safe until
everyone is safe and that's why it's key
to property to progress
it's key to vaccinate to vaccinate and
to speed up
the vaccinations campaign so on your
question
i think that it was good
to introduce the expert authorization
mechanism
indeed to create transparency
because that proves that the european
union is the most
open reliably exporting
region in the world the united states
have their executive order
i have no knowledge so far of uk exports
perhaps i'm mistaken
and waiting for that transparency
and the same goes for many other regions
in the world
so if only or only the export
authorization mechanism created the
transparency
to show how much the european
region is doing when it comes to
producing and exporting vaccines to the
world that's the first point
where i think it's encouraging for the
companies
because their their achievements are
being honored by that the second point
is
that indeed we have a strong
interest in expanding
the vaccine production in the european
union to be prepared
for the next years to be prepared
for variants to come to be prepared
for the time where we will at a certain
point in time
have to reboost uh the immunity um
against covet or covet variants
in the european union so our interest is
to intensify the cooperation with
the reliable companies the companies
that have proven
that they can scale up and that they
honor their contracts
over the next years also to invest
in that because we think in an era of
pandemic it's the right way to go
thank you madam president this concludes
our press conference of this evening
thank you all for joining
and see you soon
[Music]
you